[Music]
divinity original sin - is an RPG whose
cauldron is filled to the brim with
clever dialogue and hidden secrets so
much so that you could spend hours upon
hours in the opening area alone just
like our own Dave Jewett did you can
check out his video over on GameSpot
calm but for right now let's take a look
at seven cool things that you might have
missed in the games opening area fort
joy
[Music]
from the moment you wash ashore on the
beach it's pretty clear that you'll need
to work your way up from the bottom
luckily some essential items are nearby
but still pretty easy to miss on the
partially crumbled platform you'll find
a bedroll which will allow you to easily
heal your party outside of battle as
well as a shovel which will allow you to
uncover treasures whenever you come
across a mound of goodies sure you could
just get a lizard character to do your
diggin for you but where's the fun in
that
before you actually reach for joy though
you'll come across an innocent-looking
black cat who takes an immediate liking
to you and eventually follows you around
for a while but you'll want to do
everything in your power to keep it
alive
that means no walking through fire no
stepping in poison and don't get too
close to some superstitious guards
seriously if you do manage to keep the
cat alive you'll be handsomely rewarded
with a new companion when you leave for
joy the cat will become a familiar
meaning that you'll be able to summon
them in or out of battle and use its
teleport ability to swap places with it
not an entirely necessary thing to have
but come on you guys save the cat now if
you're in the market for some armor with
a little bit more pizzazz try getting
the teleportation gloves kill a few
Crocs for a quest and your grubby little
mitts will be blessed with the free
teleportation spell that you can use in
combat or outside of combat to help
circumvent environmental obstacles or
you can just use on any random NPC or
inanimate object
the teleportation gloves aren't the only
cool things we'll get in for joy though
there's also a healing ring that you can
obtain through the quests the murderous
Geist Magister yarrow will ask you to
confront me go
a missing inmate who's now a grotesque
looking monster yeah he's kind of been
having a bad day and unless you've got a
yarrow flower on you you're gonna have
to fight him for the ring once you have
it though the quest requires you to give
the ring back in order to complete it so
your options are as follows give it back
and have no cool healing ring you doofus
keep it and have a cool healing ring or
give it back kill yarrow and have a cool
healing ring you murderer if you have no
moral compass feel free to kill both at
least we get some nice gear to cover up
that cold cold heart of yours fancy a
fight then the arena is perfect for you
find and talk to new C for the quests
and then enter the arena through the
trapdoor on the ground you'll have to
fight your way through a bunch of
enemies and if you succeed you'll be
deemed the one now as the one you'll be
able to visit a blacksmith to remove
your source collar which actually if you
do it too early could pose a problem for
your character while it's probably the
easiest method to get off the Magisters
that you run into will promptly throw
you in prison afterwards making getting
anything done and town a hassle so maybe
wait till you're almost ready to leave
to do the arena also fun fact if you're
interested in bringing a friend with you
into the arena your friendly co-op
session will eventually turn into a
fight to the death as there can only be
one the one so make sure you decide
amongst yourselves who's gonna be the
one before you actually start
[Laughter]
there's no shortage of cool things to
create into van de original sin - and as
a rule of thumb always pick up and read
as many books as possible not only is
reading good for you but these crafting
books have recipes for spells food and
other helpful items so make sure you
scour Fort Joy high and low for these
now what's an adventure without some
great party members to experience it
with while it's entirely possible to go
it alone you'll definitely want to
recruit some hearty teammates to help
you in your journey and for joy is a
first and most convenient place to do it
the red prints is hard to miss as he's
located outside of Fort joy near the
beach you wash ashore on Beast is also
located on the beach over to the west of
Griffes camp he'll be fixing up a wreck
ship civil can be found stalking the
lizard sting tail you'll first see here
near Griffes camp and afterward she'll
be near sting tales camp which is to the
west of the elf cave low sea is pretty
hard to miss she's right in front of the
fort joy Waypoint shrine and a faun is
equally hard to miss once you enter the
fort you'll hear a commotion over some
thugs harassing an elf and a faun
defending her intervene and then talk to
a fawn and finally Fain's location can
be a little bit tricky and is pretty
easy to miss head north out of Fort joy
follow the path on the right side and
you'll come across a hidden alcove go
through it and you'll find Fane leaning
over a body of course with a healthy
number of party members to choose from
come some hard decisions as well
unfortunately you can only have four
party members at a time which means that
some of them will be left back in fort
joy you can swap them in and out and
give each character a trial run but
sadly you're eventually going to have to
give a few of them the boot you'll also
be able to decide the class of each
party member and if you mess up it'll be
a good long while until you can change
it so think very carefully about your
team's composition we'll have a
character class guide coming up soon so
if you're uncertain about which one to
choose make sure to watch out for that
now if you've got any tips for people
just starting now or even for those late
in the game put in the comments below
and maybe we'll feature in the next
video we're just getting started with
the game so please make sure to stay
tuned the game spot as we'll have plenty
more videos coming for you very soon my
name is Joey thanks for watching